au lendemain de la manifestation
nationale à paris ils étaient près de
400 à battre le pavé dans les rues de
tours restaurateurs gérants de bars et
de boîtes de nuit ont crié leur colère
face à la non réouverture de leur
établissement malgré le respect du
protocole sanitaire certains ne voient
pas comment s'en sortir ni même s'ils
pourront rouvrir l'an prochain hélène
chapelet d'habitude ils passent leurs
journées derrière un comptoir ou dans
les cuisines de leur établissement les
gérants de bars et de restaurants et
leurs salariés était de sortie cet après
midi pour réclamer la réouverture de
leurs établissements considérés comme
des commerces non essentiels ils sont
fermés depuis le 30 octobre dernier sans
perspective claire de réouverture le coc
vite dans nos établissements je pense
qu'on nous a donnée à ces mesures à
respecter pour qu'aujourd'hui on a su
les mettre en place
on a su assurer toutes ces mesures les
mettre en place les faire suivre par nos
clients et je trouve ça aberrant qu
aujourd'hui on nous ait stoppé au moins
de novembre dans nos établissements par
rapport à d'autres endroits où c'est pas
respecté monsieur castex a encore dit
que le 20 janvier s'était pas sûr qu'on
a qu'on puisse ouvrir et que
malheureusement beaucoup beaucoup de
promesses les aides ont du mal à venir
et on craint pour nos entreprises pour
l'emploi de nos salariés dans le cortège
tourangeau également des gérants de
discothèques mais aussi un distributeur
de boissons un secteur oubliés dont
l'activité est intimement liée aux bars
et restaurants
dès que les bars et les restaurants fait
ferme suite à des mesures de fermeture
administrative nous on est à l'art est
totalement avec des stops qui tourne
plus avec des dates sur des produits qui
sont des dates courbe qui vont se
périmer et qui vont être obligés de
jeter
de plus tous les coûts fixes quelque
part que qu'on peut pas couvrir parce
qu'on a aujourd'hui aucune aide ni lé
fonds de solidarité on allait pge mais
faudra les rembourser et encore faut que
les banquiers puissent me suivre mais
aujourd'hui on demande simplement est
reconnue au même titre que les acteurs
de cette profession à la fin de l'année
à cause des deux confinement les bars et
restaurants auront cumulé quatre mois et
demi de fermeture
quant aux discothèques elles afficheront
huit mois d'inactivité